this German group has been touring Iran
for one week they're just about to
return home the country's pulsating
capital of Tehran was the high point for
most of them their itinerary includes
museums and the Grand Bazaar which they
already knew from photos but their
personal contacts with the local people
proved to be quite different from what
they had expected
to tithe soup I denied the people were
really super very polite and courteous
they were always asking me where I come
from and offered me tea it was much more
than I had expected people at home are
astonished when you say you're going to
Iran they can't believe you can just go
there but once you're here you get
settled in right away so it's quite
normal to immediately start getting
around but they have to observe the
Islamic dress code and they're only
allowed to travel in a group not on
their own Tehran population 15 million
is a modern metropolis many Iranians
think tourism is their country's
greatest opportunity now that the
international isolation is ending and
plenty of people hope it will prove to
be a personal source of income Iran has
lots of well-educated young people but
unemployment is enormous Raisa Dennis
wah works in tourism specializing in
taking care of German tour groups
he knows Germany and speaks the language
fluently this year more than 5 million
foreign tourists visited Iran 25 percent
more than last year
if tourism continues to go well of
course there will be good opportunities
for those who want to work in this
industry and I could imagine there will
be jobs not only in the restaurant trade
but also in travel agencies and as tour
guides and so on that's a very important
positive factor in order to reduce
unemployment but Iran needs more modern
Western standard hotels the pent-up
demand is enormous Raisa fields plenty
of complaints and discusses them with
tour guides
the German group visits the golestan
palace at the end of its tour of Tehran
formerly it was the seat of government
for the Shah now it's a museum the
Germans were pleased with their visit to
Iran and can't wait to tell their
friends and families all about it